This is for posterity.
Little do they know.
Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambuddhassa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
Up until now we've been talking about the process of vipassana, how to establish right awareness,
come stabilire la giusta consapevolezza e come risvegliare questa intelligenza.
E abbiamo lavorato principalmente con gli ostacoli, gli impedimenti.
Spero ora, da questo giorno avanti, che ci siano più e più piccoli
islets of peace and joy.
Magari.
So, now it's time to look at the positive side of the practice.
Adesso è giunta l'ora di guardare l'aspetto positivo della pratica.
E quelle virtù che dobbiamo sviluppare.
Queste noi chiamiamo i sette fattori dell'illuminazione.
E cercherò poi più in là di unirli alle cinque facoltà spirituali.
Ma prima di iniziare il discorso vorrei fare un piccolo esercizio in cui voi cominciate a riconoscere, a separare questi sette fattori.
Quindi se vi mettete in una postura di meditazione,
E centratevi sul respiro.
E la prima posizione, potremmo dire, è diventare consapevoli del respiro.
E possiamo notare i suoi attributi grossi.
Possiamo notare i suoi attributi grossolani.
Se è un respiro corto, se è un respiro lungo, come riempie l'addome, se lo riempie tutto oppure solo un pochino.
Poi cominciamo a sentire le sensazioni sottili del respiro.
Permette la delicatezza del respiro
e portare calma.
Forse hai sentito questo tipo di calma quando sei stato su una piazza, sollevando magari l'Adriatico e guardando le nuvole che vengono e andranno.
Forse avete provato questo tipo di canna seduti sulla spiaggia osservando l'Adriatico, il mare Adriatico, e guardando le onde che andavano e venivano.
Lasciate che questa calma porti uno stato di stallo nella mente, una mente ferma.
Cominciate ad apprezzare, a godere di queste sensazioni così calme.
Adesso per cominciare a vedere un pochino più chiaramente, molto lentamente focalizziamo sulle sensazioni spirituali.
Cominciamo a diventare consapevoli dell'inizio, dell'inspirazione, della fine dell'inspirazione, dell'inizio della espirazione e della fine della espirazione.
Grazie.
Quindi lasciate sorgere quel senso di interesse con la domanda qual è questa sensazione?
Assicuratevi che state guardando, osservando il respiro, non state cercando qualcosa.
Sviluppate questo atteggiamento del ricevere delle informazioni.
Come se stessi ascoltando la radio.
E diventare più consapevoli del processo, della natura cambiante del salire e del scendere.
Quindi abbiamo iniziato semplicemente osservando, seguendo questa consapevolezza.
E abbiamo permesso a questa delicatezza del respiro di portarsi in uno stato di calma, di quieto.
Abbiamo sviluppato un certo senso di apprezzamento per ciò che c'era, era bello essere lì.
Poi abbiamo fatto un piccolo sforzo per mettere a fuoco, per vedere più chiaramente.
Poi abbiamo sollevato un certo interesse in ciò che stavamo guardando.
Stando attenti solo a guardare, a non cercare qualcosa, siamo rimasti aperti a ciò che dicevamo
Poi siamo diventati consapevoli o più consapevoli di questo fattore del cambiamento della transitorietà.
Questo è il mio piccolo esercizio
Una delle abilità che il meditatore deve sviluppare è come far crescere questi sette fattori.
Quindi scordiamoli uno a uno, in modo che voi ne conosciate un po' i pro e i contro, oppure gli equilibri, e sappiate come funzionano.
Molti di questi fattori di illuminazione si trovano anche nei cinque cosiddetti...
Facoltà spirituali.
La prima di queste è la fede o saddha.
La fede nel buddismo non è da essere scambiata con la credenza.
La fede è semplicemente fiducia.
Se non abbiamo fiducia cominciamo a soffrire del dubbio.
Come facciamo a sostenere questa nostra fiducia nel Dhamma, fiducia nella pratica?
Quindi attraverso i tre processi di saggezza che si sostiene questa fiducia.
Il primo processo è di ascoltare il Dharma.
quindi o leggendo i libri o ascoltando però ascoltando in un modo aperto senza aver paura di ricevere delle informazioni perché non ci viene chiesto di crederci quindi non dobbiamo aver paura di ricevere un lavaggio del cervello
Possiamo semplicemente ascoltare e ricevere.
Potrebbe sorgere in voi una sorta di gioia nel sentire che state ascoltando qualcosa che
Ma questa conoscenza trasmessa deve diventare la nostra stessa conoscenza attraverso un processo di pensare, di ragionarci su.
E quindi attraverso questo ragionarci su, al parlarne con altri, che questa conoscenza diventa la nostra, conoscenza intellettuale.
Per esempio, quando leggo un libro di scienze,
Per esempio, se leggo un libro di scienze e leggo la teoria della relatività di Einstein, io la posso capire.
Più o meno.
Ma quando cerco di spiegarlo non ci riesco.
Quindi, anche se io ho una certa comprensione della teoria della relatività, non dico la fisica, ma la matematica,
Io posso comprendere questa conoscenza, ma non è mia, nel senso che non la posso spiegare a qualcun altro.
quindi lì vedete la differenza può essere capitato nella vostra vita di aver compreso delle cose ma poi non riuscire a spiegarle questo significa che non è la vostra conoscenza quindi fino adesso è a livello intellettuale e sostiene la fede sostiene la fiducia c'è anche un altro lato di fiducia che ha più a che fare con il cuore
c'è un altro lato della fiducia che ha più a che fare con il cuore quindi ci sono dei casi nelle scritture in cui una persona semplicemente vedendo il Buddha ha questa fiducia e segue lo segue
Quando ero in Ceco-Slovacchia uno dei meditatori mi ha detto che stava stando in una chiesa aspettando l'autobus.
E tutti stavano cambiando, muovendo, restando, guardando e parlando.
ma c'era il monaco buddista c'era un monaco assolutamente fermo e in pace e questo lo ha colpito come molto ammirabile e ha inquietato sul buddismo a causa di questo
quindi non è solo un processo intellettuale può anche essere il conoscere delle persone o per esempio lui conosce una persona che è entrata in un tempio semplicemente vedendo la statua del Buddha c'è stata una connessione
Quindi la terza parte è quella di stabilirla come la nostra conoscenza esperienziale.
Questo è chiamato vipassana mayapanya, cioè la saggezza dell'insight.
Nonostante la fede può ancora essere messa in dubbio finché uno non ha fatto esperienza del nirvana.
A quel punto non ci potrà più essere nessun dubbio riguardo all'insegnamento del Buddha perché loro stessi l'hanno sperimentato.
E a quel punto la parola usata dal Buddha non è una facoltà spirituale ma un potere spirituale.
Quindi qui vediamo una balanza tra la fiducia e la fiducia e la crescita, prima di tutto, dell'intelligenza intellettuale, ma principalmente dell'intelligenza esperienziale.
Scusate, qui vediamo la crescita tra la fiducia e la conoscenza.
E qui vediamo la crescita, l'equilibrio tra la fede e la saggezza attraverso questi tre processi della conoscenza ricevuta.
la conoscenza resa propria quindi intellettuale e l'insight la sentenza dell'insight la conoscenza data dall'insight now to support that wisdom in our practice now that we take this insight into the practice to get that insight it must be supported by the quality of equanimity
questa parola equanimità viene fuori in tante diverse liste nella tradizione Theravada credo che sapete che Theravada specialmente è una collezione di liste
Yeah, one of these, two of those, ten of them, and so on.
è così e non ci si può parlare quindi questa equanimità qui non si riferisce a un stato di calma di cuore o qualcosa del genere si riferisce a un stato di calma di cuore
è riferito a un atteggiamento di apertura quindi un atteggiamento in cui si è disponibili a ricevere qualsiasi cosa arrivi lo si può paragonare a un giudice che non deve essere confuso dai cleveri argomenti dei giudici
che non deve essere confuso da queste argomentazioni brillanti degli avvocati e non deve essere come dire deve essere irremovibile rispetto ai movimenti della folla rimanete rimanete
so hang him hang him scusate impiccatelo the baying we say the baying of the crowd like dogs baying baying no no baying you know ullari ecco
Quindi abbiamo questi due fattori dell'illuminazione il primo è questo mayapagna quindi il potere dell'investigazione e l'altro è il sostegno
e questa qualità di investigazione si chiama Dhamma Vichya, investigare il Dhamma e la qualità di questa ripassamento e ricordate che essenzialmente questa investigazione è attraverso le tre caratteristiche dell'esistenza
Quindi fondamentalmente questa investigazione è sulle tre caratteristiche dell'esistenza.
Aniccia, Dukkha e Anatta.
Impermanenza, non soddisfazione e non senso.
Ci sono tante altre cose che impareremo sulla nostra psicologia, ma sono queste tre cose che cambieranno il nostro rapporto con il mondo.
Ora...
Gli altri due fattori che sostengono questa investigazione sono la calma e l'interesse.
Quindi io non ho fatto altro che guidarvi nella meditazione così come ha fatto il Buddha nel suo discorso Satipatthana
Quindi dice di allenarsi al respiro per diventare calmo.
Calmi il corpo, calmi la mente.
lui ha dato proprio istruzioni di calmare il corpo, calmare la mente per stare sul respiro prima ha detto conoscete il respiro, se è lungo, se è corto, delle cose così molto grossolane e poi usate il respiro, usate questo per portare questa calma al mento, al cuore
E poi si usa questo respiro per portare questa calma nella mente e nel cuore.
E quella calma sostiene l'interesse.
Alcuni di voi possono sapere che la parola per interesse è piti.
Così come upeka, l'equanimità, assume diversi significati a seconda della pratica che si sta facendo.
Qualche volta piti significa gioia.
Ma qui nella pratica significa interesse ed è quell'interesse che sicuramente avete provato anche voi quando avete studiato qualcosa di molto interessante o fatto un lavoro che vi interessava.
A volte l'interesse può essere così grande che trovate che state salivando, trovate la saliva in bocca.
Quindi questo interesse è una qualità del cuore.
quindi vedete che questa qualità dell'interesse sostiene l'investigazione perché voi volete sapere il desiderio di conoscere il voler conoscere questo è fondamentale a tutti gli esseri
Tutte le creature vogliono conoscere.
Ho avuto una piccola esperienza di questo tipo con un cane.
Malesia.
e aveva messo un tavolino fuori con una rete e una zanzariera e mi sono seduto sul tavolo con una tazza di caffè sotto questa zanzariera e stavo aspettando di osservare il calare del sole il tramonto è stato solo dopo un po' che ho realizzato che stavo avanti a destra
Anche in questo caso comunque non mi sono scoraggiato.
E quindi ho continuato a sedermi.
E c'erano sempre questi due cani che venivano lì nella capanna e continuavano a girare, erano grandi amici e si ricorrevano.
E quindi ha perso questo primo cane e ha cominciato a piangere perché non ha visto il suo amico.
Questo amico non si è fatto vedere.
Quindi quando è arrivato questo cane è arrivato da dietro la casa e ha visto questa cosa
Ovviamente qualcosa che non aveva mai visto prima.
E anche se il suo amico era intorno a lui e saltava e faceva un sacco di altre cose,
assolutamente fermo e mi guardava e si chiedeva cosa stesse succedendo la cosa incredibile quindi questa intelligenza c'è in tutti gli esseri viventi in un certo grado
Quindi ora abbiamo fatto quattro, beh abbiamo fatto cinque facoltà spirituali, che sono questa, prima di tutto, questa equanimità, la volontà di ricevere, l'apertura, balanzate con questa investigazione.
Oh yeah, well, sorry, ok, four.
Ripetiamo un attimo.
Quattro, ok.
Sorry.
Oh yes, we've only done, yes, I'll correct myself.
We have now done four of the seven spiritual, of the seven factors of enlightenment.
Quattro.
l'equilibrio tra l'equanimità e l'investigazione e l'equilibrio tra la calma e l'interesse se c'è troppo interesse e non abbastanza calma allora ci agitiamo
E questa calma, se non c'è interesse, può portarci in un bello e bello dormimento.
E è lo stesso con l'equanimità e la conoscenza.
Se c'è questa investigazione senza l'apertura, allora ci stiamo guardando da una certa posizione.
è lo stesso se c'è troppa investigazione senza la saggezza noi senza equanimità noi staremo guardando da un punto di vista particolare quindi che ci piaccia o no la nostra intelligenza è già in qualche modo stata condizionata dai nostri pregiudizi dalla nostra cultura ed educazione
quindi mettiamo tutto questo da parte aprendo la nostra intelligenza tutto ciò che arriva non useremo un filtro per lasciare fuori nulla quindi
Quindi, ora, i prossimi due, di nuovo, che devono essere equilibrati, sono l'esercizio e la concentrazione.
Ora, la concentrazione ci presenta un po' di problemi, perché la parola ci porta a scuola e ai genitori, e ci rende molto stretti.
Concentratevi!
la parola concentrazione crea un po' un problema perché ci riporta a situazioni di scuola di famiglia o di genitori ci rende molto tesi perché è sempre stato detto di ascoltare di concentrarci
Quindi se dite a qualcuno tutti devi concentrare probabilmente diventano molto tesi.
Quindi la parola che io ho usato nel nostro esercizio era mettere a fuoco.
Quindi potete prendere ad esempio una macchina fotografica e quando volete vedere qualcosa allora dovrete girare l'obiettivo per mettere a fuoco.
Quindi l'unico sforzo che dobbiamo fare, così come giriamo l'obiettivo, è quello di mettere a fuoco l'oggetto.
E anche, ovviamente, solo l'energia fisica di mantenere l'obiettivo eretto.
chiaramente anche lo sforzo fisico di tenere il corpo in una posizione retta.
O almeno sveglio.
Quindi, di nuovo, se c'è troppo sforzo e non abbastanza
fuoco diciamo messo a fuoco allora si diventa agitati quindi quando vi trovate in questo stato di calma e cominciate a osservare delle cose e diventate agitati chiedetevi ma sto cercando qualcosa o sono solo cercando qualcosa
sto semplicemente osservando perché se stiamo solo osservando solo ricevendo allora non ci dovrebbe essere l'inrequietezza se c'è troppo invece messa a fuoco diciamo
senza l'energia che lo sostiene allora potremmo addormentarci allora ci sono due tipi di sonno il primo è quello che conosciamo ed è quando noi inconsapevolmente andiamo giù e ci inchinassimo al buddha
Ma quando c'è questa buona energia, una buona meditazione, allora il meditatore è...
Ma ha perso la conoscenza.
Ma chiunque vede il meditatore dice, ah, lì c'è un buon meditatore.
Ma sono completamente inconsapevoli.
e a seconda di quanto è forte la meditazione possono stare in questo stato un'ora, due ore e il meditatore quando si sveglia può dire ah io ho alcune di queste facoltà ben sviluppate ma ho appena perso due ore
perché non c'è nessun insight nell'oblivio quindi il meditatore viene a conoscere quello che non va qui e che non c'è abbastanza sforzo
Quando cominciate a comprendere tutto questo può sembrare molto complicato.
Non vorrei che questo discorso vi portasse poi nella vostra meditazione a ragionare, ah, troppa concentrazione.
E quindi, per fortuna, il Buddha l'ha reso molto semplice.
Ha detto che il fattore guida che porterà su per assorgere tutti questi fattori e tutti nella giusta misura è la consapevolezza.
Quindi effettivamente questo discorso è stato una perdita di tempo.
Quindi tutto quello che dobbiamo fare è far sorgere la retta consapevolezza e poi tutto sorgerà
nel modo giusto e nei tempi giusti quindi questa qualità di consapevolezza giusta è di assoluta importanza e può essere molto aiutante avere qualche tipo di memoria dove sai che sei stato in un stato di consapevolezza giusta
quindi è molto utile avere un qualche ricordo di un momento in cui voi sapete di essere stati nella giusta consapevolezza e qui possiamo tornare alla storia della vita del Buddha se ricordate, lui è arrivato a un punto dove lui è arrivato a un punto dove aveva perso la speranza
di trovare una risposta e in quel senso di degezione ha persino lasciato i suoi compagni e stava a destra della strada guardando molto depresso
Quindi erano seduti lungo la strada con un aspetto molto depresso.
Quando passò di lì suggiata una donna per un'offerta per un tempio di vicino.
Ma vedendo questo uomo così depresso, così magro
ha offerto a lui quello che lei stava portando alla divinità.
Quindi non vi stupirete se l'ambrosia, cioè il cibo degli dèi, che lei stava portando a questa divinità, era un budino di riso.
è il riso bollito nel latte con il miele con un po' di cardamomo e un po' di cannella quindi ha bevuto questo e si è rinvigorato
lui l'ha mangiato e si è ripreso forza ed è proprio mangiando questo riso che era una delizia per i bambini che lui si ricordò un fatto venuto nella sua infanzia
Quindi si ricorda da bambino, si ricorda se stesso da bambino seduto sotto un albero che guardava suo padre che eseguiva una cerimonia beneaugurale per la stagione della natura.
Quindi è stata la qualità di quel guardare, di quello osservare che era così diverso da tutto ciò che aveva imparato dai suoi studi, dai suoi insegnanti, dal suo addestramento.
Ciò che aveva riscoperto era il modo di un bambino
Sono sicuro che tutti avete visto un bambino di tre, quattro, cinque anni quando vede qualcosa che non ha mai visto prima, come un insetto.
si focalizzano completamente su quella piccola creatura e non arrivano da nessuna altra idea perché non sanno che cosa sia e la cosa più importante è che il loro cuore si tocca questo significa che non c'è nessun pensiero
In meditazione, se rilassate questo, potrete vedere che il pensiero si ferma.
Ci aiuta a fermare il pensiero.
Anche la lingua.
Normalmente, ovviamente, quando un parente vede un bambino così, gli dicono di chiudere la bocca perché sembrano così insensibili.
e così distruggere tutte le speranze dell'enlightenment in questa vita
Vi ricordate l'esercizio che vi ho fatto fare di guardare nel palmo della mano solo per
esercitare l'occhio a effettivamente vedere ciò che c'è
Quindi cercate di sviluppare questa capacità di osservare gli oggetti in questo modo, come vi ho suggerito con un fiore o con una pietra.
Quindi di sviluppare questa pura consapevolezza.
Conosco un artista in Belgio che gestisce un centro di meditazione.
ha detto che ha passato 25 anni ad andare nello stesso albero nella stessa foresta a dipingere quell'albero ripetutamente in modo da chiarire la mente di tutti i concetti del tre in modo che potesse dipingere il tre
Ora dipinge statue Buddha, facce Buddha che hanno una certa qualità distinta.
Questo è ciò di cui dobbiamo essere consapevoli nella nostra pratica.
Quindi questa è un'altra cosa di cui dobbiamo essere consapevoli nella nostra pratica.
Dobbiamo sviluppare questi fattori.
Ricordiamoci che è bene cominciare ogni meditazione con quella mente che sembra quella di un bambino.
molto rilassata molto aperta che guarda semplicemente che osserva e ogni volta che lo perdiamo durante la meditazione perché siamo agitati
fermatevi e tornate all'inizio non importa quante volte lo facciamo un milione di volte in una seduta non importa quante volte lo facciamo anche un milione di volte in una seduta è per questo che lo chiamiamo avvestimento se pensate agli atleti come ai giocatori di tennis spengono 6 ore al giorno battendo una palla sopra il topo di un netto
Backhand, forward hand, over the top.
And that's just for a gold cup.
Which most of them never get.
Almeno noi qui, prima o poi, arriveremo alla piena liberazione.
Questa è la promessa del Buddha.
Tutti gli esseri saranno liberati.
Questo è proprio il modo in cui la coscienza si
Solo in un'occasione è stata pronunciata l'eresia che alcune persone non ce l'avrebbero fatta.
Sono state chiamate queste persone che non ce l'avrebbero fatta, così come è detto nell'altra lezione Mahayana.
e Ichikanti significa che loro continueranno a rinascere per sempre Ichikanti significa andare avanti, avanti, avanti ed è la stessa parola del Samsara Samsara è il mondo dell'eterno divenire
Ci fermiamo per un momento e lasciamo che solga qualsiasi pensiero che deve sorgere.
quindi la cosa importante da realizzare è che ci sono dei fattori che vanno sviluppati e che questi si svilupperanno abbastanza naturalmente ogni volta che noi stabilizzeremo questa giusta consapevolezza
E questo in un certo senso è l'unico scopo della nostra pratica.
Se voi doveste ridurre tutti gli insegnamenti del Buddha in una sola parola, questo sarebbe Sati.
retta consapevolezza.
Spero che le mie parole siano state di una qualche utilità per voi e sinceramente mi auguro che voi siate liberati prima piuttosto che poi.